more DC news coming our way
yeah Superman Shazam - and Black Adam
announced a breakdown Justice League
Easter eggs this is coming from the
channel emergency awesome and we'll talk
about it afterwards because I was like
oh she's a I'm soon black Adam wasn't
aware of any of the news in that
department let's get into it see what's
in store
Andrey Campbell returning really loved
what he was more of a Nancy by the end
of Justice League I listened to the
trailer number two song when I work out
does it make you feel super that's funny
John Henry Cavill Superman Man of Steel
videos they just confirmed that he's
actually coming back and we found out
which movies he's coming back for if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe I'm so happy when it was on
that mirror Superman DC movie
predictions on the video she's just
working our way down the list here
starting with number five because of all
the Justice League Snyder cut hype
that's been happening the past week in
Zack Snyder using a Man of Steel
Superman rewatched party with Henry
Cavill to announce the project a lot of
us assumed that it was implied he was at
least in the process of trying to work
out a new deal with Warner Brothers to
come back to everyman movies or more Man
of Steel movies or at least show up as
Superman in some DC movie in some way
because he'd always said ever since
Justice League that he's not done with
the Superman character he has tons of
ideas he's been pitching Warner Brothers
for a while now on a Man of Steel sequel
just a couple hours ago as I'm making a
pitching ideas he is in the process of
hammering out a deal for multiple get
multiple of new Superman crossovers in
new DC movies it sounds like some of
them will do several others but we also
found out which movies those are going
to now's the perfect time to return man
publicly acknowledging that they're
developing Man of Steel 2 or another
solo Superman movie of any kind
supposedly the New Deal Henry Cavill is
making is to crossover with their
upcoming movies like Shazam cross Jack
Adam
than Aquaman - there's also the flash
movie - because they're doing flashpoint
obviously are the net versions of the
characters would come in handy Superman
would fit in pretty well with that theme
oh my god I created the injustice
Superman what have I done now and even
though it goes without saying it
wouldn't make sense for him to do Wonder
Woman 1984 since they'd already finished
the movie and it's set before Superman's
crash to earth he's not gonna show up
during the Batman movie with Robert
Pattinson but they'd already tried to
get him to cameo at the end of the first
shows a movie so we already knew that
they were trying to cross him over with
other new movies the rock also has
history with Superman in the Black Adam
movie that predates the Shazam movie
post-credits scene in his memo has been
trying to get everybody to cameo in his
sequel so curry
right now the DC movie release order
works like this one of those HBO Mac
shows then they do shows the m2 then
they do Aquaman - Shazam Q isn't
supposed to be a big black out of
crossover maybe it post-credit scene
teaser at the end but Zachary Levi said
they don't have big plans for black
attitude and part three man focused on
this magic lands plot that I've talked
about in my previous Shazam videos but
because Superman inches am have so much
history in the comics it makes sense
that they try to use Superman inches and
to at least as a guide to help Billy
with problems that he can't solve with
magic or punching remember he's just a
high school kid so there's a lot that he
does not know about being a superhero
Superman even kind of beat this was the
first movie but he does give off a lot
of dad because Superman scene at the end
of the movie we know that Billy
canonically already knows Superman
and based on the logic of this scene
there would have had to have been at
least a small time jump between this
scene at the rock of eternity where
they're putting the seven deadly sins
back in their prison then at some point
before the cafeteria seen Billy probably
was approached by a Superman or even the
full Justice League who just saw what
happened in Philadelphia and as you
would expect Superman or the Justice
League to do fly their way to
Philadelphia to see what the hell was
going on and find out what exactly was
going on with this high school kid that
happens to look like an adult Zachary
Levi said he's been campaigning to try
and get a Wonder Woman inches am2 as
well but I don't know that's gonna wind
up happening whatever their plans for
Wonder Woman three are because they're
definitely making Wonder Woman
three so he might be busy doing that I
love how the cast members are trying to
get them to cross over and there's no
what's opting for it Superman is weak
against magical attacks but he can't
help dishes Amelie with all their other
non-traditional abilities like super
strength speed Superman to be a huge
part of Shazam - but number two Superman
versus Black Adam so the news report
mentions crossbow you got a bill up to
that matter movie which is a bit of a
surprise no not Harry cavils management
company is run by The Rock's ex-wife who
also still manages the rock rocks known
each other for a long time
they're already bros in real life and
even before henry cavill signed with
their king the rock had been trying to
pitch superman vs Black Adam to Warner
Brothers for a while really I didn't
know about that ago in my Black Adam
video but boss logic said a couple years
ago after the rocket started to talk
more about the Black Adam movie openly
he attacked at him to create some cool
fan tour of Black Adam fighting Superman
if you've never seen it there's actually
a great animated movie where Superman
effectively goes up against Black Adam
he gets his ass handed to him but it's
still a religious I have a save the baby
you are my physical match but I sense
one critical difference I hope though I
hope Dwayne Johnson does that boys last
year we heard a society storyline that
they were planning on doing in the Black
Adam movie there wasn't any mention of
Superman anywhere in that script but it
sounds like what's changed now is all
the Justice League Snyder cut stuff just
been going on since last November has
healed whatever wound there was between
Warner Brothers in Henry Cavill remember
when they announced that they were
planning on doing a Supergirl movie
instead of doing Man of Steel - there
were a lot of reports that the studio is
actually just using the press to bargain
with Henry Cavill people because Henry
Cavill wanted more money but they didn't
want to pay him because of what happened
with Justice League so apparently they
probably never planned on doing a
Supergirl movie and they were just
holding that over his head in order to
get him to take a lower paycheck Oh
the debacle will happen when it came out
in theaters I think originally Warner
Brothers never had plans to do Superman
versus black out him but when Justice
League did so poorly it is all there DC
movie plans maybe they just warmed up a
little to the idea of a more hardcore
version of Superman inside the Black
Adam movies but before today before they
made this big announcement my assumption
was is that we wouldn't see Superman in
a black atom movie at least until one of
the sequels so number one I just did a
blackout of video a couple days ago I'll
link it at the end of this but I talked
about the Justice Society storyline
that's supposed to happen during that
movie at least in the current version of
the script as it exists now if they're
talking about putting Superman in the
Black Adam movie he obviously probably
would not be part of the Justice Society
just because within the context of the
DC timeline the Justice League's still
exists in present day they're still
operating all over the world the whole
thing with the Justice Society in the
Black Adam movie is that they're
reforming in present day because they
fought him in the past at some point and
even though we haven't seen the Snyder
cut ending of Justice League yet during
the end of that movie they sort of
implied that he's back working at the
Daily Planet and things are relatively
back to normal what it's pretty awesome
Aquaman - that just feels like it would
be the Aquaman is Superman don't spend a
ton of time hanging out in the comics by
themselves unless it's a bigger Justice
League team-up story but they're both
children of two worlds they're both
treated like outsiders their whole lives
never really belonging anywhere but
somehow they feel responsible for
protecting everyone protecting the earth
as their chosen home so Superman going
to Atlanta it feels like a fun premise
even if it's only for a little bit of
that movie I wonder how much interaction
between Superman with the Black Manta by
himself
is one of Aquaman's main villains but
just by himself he isn't powerful enough
to take on Aquaman with his new upgraded
armor and trident but Aquaman 2 is a
little further off so it's gonna be a
while before we get more news about that
in in terms of the movie crossover
everyone seen the original flashpoint
storyline that version of Superman's pod
was actually captured by the US
government and he was kept in captivity
so he winds up being they killed her
weakened version of Superman I don't
think that they would do something like
that
in the flash movie they already sit-ins
are going to
that we knew original comic book version
of flashpoint and then I can't be doing
all the Justice League characters and
down we don't know if there's gonna be
any kind of Batman or Wonder Woman cameo
but the way they've been talking about
the flash movie it wouldn't be quite so
dark as justice or traditional
flashpoint type of that it's such a good
adaptation guys haven't seen it right
now it was just for a couple big
crossovers I think if those go well then
they'll start thinking about doing more
Superman solo movies so it's not like
they'll never do Man of Steel 2 or
whatever they want to call it man of
tomorrow Henry Cavill has actually
talked about his ideas for more Superman
movies it for the past couple of years
he was pitching new Superman movies to
Warner Brothers for whatever reason they
didn't want to make but what'll happen
is any more news or concrete details
about which movies and what he'd be
doing in those movies of course I'll do
a video about it Zack Snyder will be
releasing a bunch more Snyder cut stuff
throughout the rest of the year as they
start to work on that movie so don't
worry those two be plenty of big DC
stuff happening and we have Wonder Woman
1984 coming out in August - hey click
here and click here for my new Black
Adam teaser and plot synopsis breakdown
covers so much in here in my opinion I
think now is the absolute perfect time
for Henry Cavill to at least you know
get some type of confirmation that he is
returning because post Justice League
he's had a couple of really great things
happen outside of the hole you know
Superman presents because he's done
obviously The Witcher he was the villain
in Mission Impossible fall out had a lot
of great work since his time as Superman
and then he liked what he showed up on
the V Rho app and then you know a little
bit prior before that I brought this up
in our Snyder it got bid you seemed like
he didn't really care if there was a
Schneider cook or not so for him to show
up in that stream and really should be
the main face for showing the support
out of all the Justice League members I
thought it was an amazing thing and it
just got me really excited the
opportunity for him to return as
Superman I guess the question that
remains though what kind of Superman
will
ultimately be I imagine that no matter
what with Zack Snyder's Justice League
he was supposed to so at least arc
somewhat into the Superman that we saw
him at the end of the just weed in
addition where he's a little bit more
like the traditional Superman because I
could see the discussion being brought
up well it's gonna be more in tune with
how he's supposed to be in Zack Snyder's
Justice League which won't come out for
a year from now or is he supposed to be
more like Joss Whedon's and I think
they're the way they both are fairly be
the same I I know that in Zack Snyder's
he's supposed to go like into the black
suit and be a lot more dark eventually
he should be back to being you know good
Superman I just think right now would be
absolutely perfect for him to return and
I had no idea that he was pitching his
own ideas for what a Man of Steel sequel
ought to be yeah I mean that was kind of
the funnest part of this whole video is
learning how much the cast seems to care
about these characters and wants to
pitch these stories I mean we've already
heard about Ezra Miller doing that but
then the rock doing that and Henry
Cavill like and that's inspiring to me
you know I haven't loved any of the
takes of his Superman on the big screen
just yet but it feels nice to know that
he cares that much about it and I feel
like the passage of time is a very
important factor here because you know
part of the big complaint about the DCU
at first was no no guys slow down take
your time and I feel like with all the
controversy and then all the course
correction and stuff and with the recent
announcements it is a good time because
we've had enough of a moment for the
culture to sit around and go you know
what Henry Cavill still deserves that
shot to really do his definitive take on
Superman it's like if Ben Affleck didn't
come back to bat Matt's fine because a
lot of people agree that you know the
BBS while it's a flawed movie his Batman
is great whereas you know Henry Cavill
could still use that opportunity I think
to really nail Superman for everybody
yeah oh yeah it's cuz I think man if
steel especially has received
significantly more love over time like
I've always liked the movie and I've
always appreciated what Henry Cavill was
going for he was never my favorite
Superman he was one of my favorite parts
of Joss Whedon's Justice League though
just where you see him arc into by the
end of that movie and seeing the
charisma and charm that that guy has you
know he can pull off the more
traditional Superman kind of portrayal
probably still keeping in tune with that
more
of a vulnerable emotional experience
that we've seen him aim for in Man of
Steel and BBS now the question is is
like this idea of not doing a Man of
Steel - right away but having him cameo
or appear alongside other characters in
one of these movies I think it's cool
how the cast has been talking about like
you know Zachary Levi wants gal gadot to
appear in his Shazam movie and Dwayne
Johnson wants Henry Cavill Superman to
appear in the Black Adam movie which
would be cool I mean all those sound
great the one that makes the most sense
to me would be him appearing in Shazam -
yeah especially cuz the way that movie
ended and just my personal association
with my knowledge of Shazam and how that
linked it like my first introduction to
Shazam was the animated movie that was
being referenced here which is Amber
Singh Black Adam that would just be the
one that excites me the most and then
him sort of being like a bit of a mentor
to the Billy Batson character would be
something that would really work on the
flip side it's like Black Adam versus
Superman I wouldn't want that I want
there to be a build-up to that I don't
want it to just be the first black Adam
movie I think like a part two at minimum
ideally a par 3 but a minimum a part two
at part two the one that would actually
excite me the most is it just sounds the
most weird and I can't really recall
much interaction maybe in the Zack
Snyder Justice League we lit more of it
but the one that excites me the most is
the idea of Aquaman and Superman bonding
with one another because I've seen a lot
of like them having fun on our red
carpet together yeah of Jason Momoa and
Henry Cavill but in terms of Superman
and Aquaman hanging out nothing really
comes to mind or me unless I'm like
completely forgetting something that
would be the most engaging one
considering the loot they're both this
is considering like the loose bro
personality of Aquaman and then kind of
the more upstanding upright citizen
citizen portrayal of Superman yeah a lot
of fun to watch yeah totally I think
that would actually be a great way to
lead back up to both you know an
eventual Superman versus Black Adam
movie and a Man of Steel proper
follow-up sequels have him yeah I think
that's a good way also to endear us to
the character in ways that perhaps the
previous films haven't given us
bunch of chance to do and so yeah even
having him in Shazam to maybe
introducing black Adam in Shazam to and
then having some kind of thing where you
have a villain appear in two different
installments of a franchise maybe Shazam
can't finish the job so he has to go
over and fight Superman or something
like that it just seems like it spells a
lot of interesting possibilities for
this universe and it's taking my mind
away from the Marvel blueprint you know
which is nice because I think this is
another opportunity for DC to go out and
really put their stamp on what they're
doing in the films and all that and yeah
for Henry Cavill to just jump back into
a couple appearances and sequels coming
up I think that would be really funny
although I do think that we have to get
a definitive Man of Steel - even if you
don't call it Man of Steel - it has to
be some type of solo Superman movie that
is something that is needed I'm all for
all these like jumping around and -
maybe one or two these other DC movies
potentially he might be you know coming
back for a seems like you will be for
some type of additional photography or
shooting for Zack Snyder's Justice
League on HBO Mac so that being said we
need a definitive sequel I think to
really put the stamp on it well that's
the portrayal of his Superman that I
think the most people agree on and rally
around is Man of Steel him the one that
the most people I think can say yeah it
was pretty good you know yeah that's an
interesting day
and bottom line like if he's severe in
Aquaman I don't want to be in Aquaman 3
because they ended it with you know
David Kane and Stephen chin at the end
of Aquaman 1 and then even a cliffhanger
with ocean master there so I think
there's enough you know meat there to
make a proper sequel Wonder Woman 3
could actually work you know they're
well connected but we'll see we'll see
alright guys what do you think about the
thought of Henry Cavill returning as the
Man of Steel and the DC Universe leave
your thoughts down below make sure to
subscribe to the real rejects subscribed
emergency awesome if you haven't done so
already click that notification bell on
our channel so you can notify whenever
we got a video up last but not least
Zach FIFO you recently pledged to our
page around page and you know if you've
seen any of these page from the day
shoutouts you know normally I like to
have a lot of fun with a lot of detail
about who you are now you're very you're
pretty new so I don't have all the
necessary ingredients here to give you
the best shout out I know you're from
Pennsylvania and that's about it
and your name's Zach like Zack Snyder so
it works to put you in this video for
the shout out and your last name fight
bowl kind of sounds like falafel and I
love falafel those are great so that
works just as well I know that right now
you're really asking us to cover this
red vs. blue series from roosterteeth
it's a heavy consideration whether or
not we should cover it moving forward we
always do polls once we're done with
shows on patreon but we'll let you know
buddy in the meantime I want to get to
know you better I want to be able to
give you better shout outs so please
Zack falafel messes me back as soon as
you can so we can get to know each other
better and we should get some Zankou
Chicken together because they got the
best falafel Zack yeah